I am a um 100% disabled veteran but I'm
still like total impermanent and I'm
still allowed to work though I I have
pretty much all my GI Bill Bill I get a
one-time uh student federal student loan
forgiveness uh from the because of the
nature of my disability um from being in
the Navy um so I'm kind of like trying
to see like is it worth it to just go to
grad school and then just uh max out the
student loans and just get them forgiven
it seems kind of sketchy to me a little
bit well it's strange because you know
it's not right that's what I think you
don't feel this is right uhuh and I
don't feel like it's right it is sketchy
yeah well then why are you calling us
asking us if we think you should do
something sketchy CU free money makes
you do funny things Ken